in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 13th, on which we commemorate Golindakh of Persia
named Maria in baptism.
Saint Golindakh was the daughter of a noble family of Magi and had been married to a fanatical
follower of the Mausdian religion in the time of Cross-Rose I, King of Persia in the years
531-578.
She conformed to the faith of her husband, but having an instinctive aversion to the worship
of the Son and Fire aspired with all her soul to a pure, true religion.
In response to her desire, an angel showed her in the course of a vision that lasted three
days, a dark and burning place in which her idol worshipping ancestors were being punished.
He then showed her through a dormer window, another place, this one full of light, where
the multitude of the elect were rejoicing and dancing together.
She wanted to join them, but the angel held her back, saying that only those who had received
Christ's holy baptism could go in.
The flame of faith had been kindled in her heart.
Golindakh decided when she came out of this ravishment to become a Christian and begged God
to show her the way.
After the pretext of a visit to her parents, she took leave of her husband, and after having
been instructed in the truths of the Christian faith was baptized and given the name Maria.
Returning home, she desired to live according to her faith and broke off all conjugal relations
with her husband.
She, incapable of understanding a call to the spiritual life, tried in every way to persuade
her to abandon her faith in Christ and return to the pleasures of the flesh.
When his plan miscarried, he went infuri and denounced her for her apostasy.
Kostros sent one of the high dignitaries of his court to her, who promised her that the
ruler would take her among his wives if she retracted.
To this, Golindakh replied, I have espoused an eternal king, and you offer me a union
with a mortal.
The king condemned her to be imprisoned in the fortress of the oblivion at Beth Huzai,
but had been named thus because the condemned who were kept there were never more counted
among the living, and because it was forbidden on pain of death to speak their names.
The saint remained there for eighteen years without ever abating her order.
Having found other Christians in the place, she was able to learn the Psalter and the holy
scriptures in Syriac from them, and by her exhortations brought many of the pagans detained
there to the Christian religion.
The king heard about this and subjected her to cruel torture.
After the death of Kostros, his son or meast the fourth in the years 579-590 had the
saint taken out of the prison and delivered over to other torturers who exhausted all the
resources of their demonic imagination in their tortures.
Enduring torment daily, Golindakh remained steadfast and was miraculously healed of her wounds
by divine grace.
They put her in a sack full of burning cinders, but she felt as though transported into a light
filled and perfumed, nuptial chamber.
They then threw her into a ditch where there was a dragon that filled all who went near it
with terror.
She was in the ditch for four months, but instead of being devoured by the monster, she
tamed it to the point at which the beast would sleep, leaning gently against her knees
like a lamb.
During all this time the saint took no nourishment as the angel of God who had first instructed
her came to give her the grace to be no longer tormented by hunger or thirst, making the
sign of the cross on her mouth so that from then on she ate only every ten days and sometimes
more rarely.
The idolaters took her out of the ditch and remaining insensible in the face of such marvels handed
her over to a house of ill-repute, ordering the libertines to make an attempt on her virtue.
Every time though, that they went into the room, they were unable to find her as the saint
was invisible to their eyes.
Convinced that this must mean she was a sorceress, the Persians condemned her to permanent exile
and included her in a convoy of convicts, an iron collar riveted round her neck.
But an angel appeared to the jailer and ordered him to take it off.
When he refused saying that he would lose his head for doing so, the angel detached the
chain without breaking the seal and handed it to the soldier, telling him to take it to
the king as a sign that the saint has been beheaded.
From prison by the angel's intervention as the Apostle Peter had been in former times,
Galinda expressed her regret at having been denied the palm of martyrdom and sadly took
the Nisebe's road.
The angel reappeared beside her and in answer to her desire lightly smote her on the neck
with a sword.
A gush of blood reddened her clothes which acquired the property of working many healings.
Arriving in Nisebe's, she brought many pagans to the faith until the day that King Ormist
was assassinated by his son, Kostros II, who freed the captives of the preceding reign
in the summer of 590.
He had scarcely ascended the throne when he was deposed by Bachram VI Kubin, unforced
to seek refuge and protection from emperor Maudice, promising to become a Christian.
Saint Gholindok, who was known as the living martyr, and was then forward highly honored,
was invited to become part of his retinue.
She firstly undertook a pilgrimage to the Holy Land.
During this journey, she went into a church served by Monophysite monks, disciples of Severus
of Antioch.
When she went forward to receive the Holy Mysteries, she was harshly turned away by the monks.
An angel then appeared to her holding two chalices, one dark, the other shining with light,
and explained to her that the light one was the chalice of the Orthodox, while the other
was the destiny of the heretics, with whom it was not right to receive communion.
The saint went thence to Yerapulis, in Euphratesia, northeast of Aleppo, to await the arrival
of Kostros, who had gone to the tomb of Saint Surgis, of Rosafa, to return a golden cross
stolen by his father when the sanctuary was sacked.
In the meantime, Saint Domettian of Mitalini and Gregory Archbishop of Antioch sent there
to catacize the sovereign, met Saint Gholindok and learned of her valorous battles.
Thanks to the mediation of these blessed hyararchs, the king of Persia concluded a peace deal
with the emperor Mauryse, who sent an army to reestablish Kostros on the throne.
As a mark of his gratitude, Kostros gave the town of Martyropolis, Rosafa, and the fortress
of Dada to the Romans.
Saint Domettian asked Gholindok to go to Constantinople and be presented to the emperor, but she refused
the invitation, objecting that her end was near.
She set off nevertheless for the chapel of Saint Surgis of Sargothon, situated between Nisevis
and Dada.
Leaving in this sanctuary, she made her last prayer to God and fell asleep in peace on
the 13th of July in the year 591.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.